it is now legal to sell recreational pot
in California but the rollout is not
going smoothly everywhere it may be
months before the digital system
designed the truck and regulate sales is
fully operational and the drug is still
only being sold for medical purposes in
some large cities like Los Angeles and
San Francisco
Mireya Villarreal is at a marijuana
dispensary in West Hollywood that is
selling recreational marijuana
Maria good morning well good morning
here at Zen in West Hollywood you can
buy recreational marijuana right now but
just a few miles down the road in Los
Angeles that's not the case and that's
because a lot of big cities here in
California are just now allowing
businesses to apply for licenses
potential pot customers in Los Angeles
were hit with a sobering reality January
first the city just started taking
applications for licenses to sell
recreational weed today we were going to
do this the Los Angeles Way and that
means that we're gonna have to do this
responsibly cat Packer head of the
city's Department of cannabis regulation
says medical marijuana dispensaries that
have been compliant with the law will
get priority processing and even then it
could be a week before a temporary
recreational license is issued
businesses are going to have to submit
applications for review they're gonna
have to go through pre-licensing
inspections another issue the digital
system the state is using to regulate
and track recreational marijuana sales
just launched and businesses have to be
trained to input data before the state
can make it mandatory which could take
months businesses are being asked to
manually file invoices which experts say
is not only complicated but risks state
pot slipping into the black market the
rules are so onerous that it's not
really possible to do manual Ben Curran
is the CEO of green bits a company that
helps dispensaries in seven states
comply with regulations including in
California the first year is going to be
a lot of the businesses transitioning
and getting used to the new rules in
learning the differences and then
getting good at doing that at scale and
the state itself you'll see will
actually be a little bit more leaning at
the beginning while people are learning
it businesses and other people in the
industry are also could
that the relatively low number of
licenses that have been issued so far
for recreational marijuana could lead to
a dry spell if the new distribution
system fails to meet demand fast enough
Nora
all right Miranda thank you so much